on this episode I talk about wholesale
sins of my employees my favorite curse
word and I announce the three winners
[Music]
this is
[Music]
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 121 the askgaryvee show
I'm in a very good mood it's a Friday
it's gorgeous out
it's Maddalena's birthday and if you can
get their D racket it's her birthday
she's 40 years old today it's tremendous
happy 40th alina i get to announce the
winners of the contest which means one
week from today three of you from the
vaynernation will come in here and
replace india and Stefan and d-roc
figured out the Iraq figure it out and
and Steve some somebody Oh is he here I
was about know somebody's lazy on
Fridays and and I'm looking forward to
that I'm also wearing a tremendous
custom-made jet shirt from Chris H from
HC Prince Oh threats excuse me
let's not screw that up right I don't
want to ruin it for you HC threads from
Texas I appreciate it brother I saw the
whole like making of it on Instagram was
popping up I I knew it was coming but I
figured the t-shirts would just get lost
in the mail like so much else gets lost
and I'm glad we made it happen probably
cuz you were involved in the instead of
DeMaio uh and so what else is going on
heading out to see the family which is
great we're looking forward to this
weekend good solid week of work very
busy couple of shows we really were only
scheduled for one but we got in three
this week and is what you call hustle
vaynernation so we're gonna save and
build up to the announcement at the end
of the show so India let's get into the
show
John asks what is your favourite
swearword of all time John my favourite
swearword of all time is dick face
there's something about dick face that
really really you know I don't know why
but like I think when I use it people
just really like it's actually
never really thought about the word
until just right now I mean it's pretty
self-explanatory you thought it was
gonna say take place I do say that's a
very interesting strategy to start the
show I mean you know kind of feel like
you know the show's growing very quickly
and you can imagine there's a lot of
people were watching for the very very
first time that's a that's a pretty
aggressive move on question number one
of all time watching about the
askgaryvee show so welcome newbies
Daniel asks as a guy who loves hustle
and people what is the unforgivable sin
one of your employees can make what's
the unforgivable sin that one of my
employee and there's actually there's a
lot of things that I I really think are
very important to me in like not lines
in the sand but you know what's
interesting is it's funny hustle and and
people I'm not worried about people's
work ethic you know it's funny actually
I've been thinking for d-roc Stefan I've
been thinking about making a video
actually about you know hustle maybe my
superpower right but it doesn't have to
be yours right back to everybody's
strengths and weaknesses mine just you
know I'm a little bit concerned that a
lot of you who are watching this you
know you hear my mantra of hard work
24/7 365 and you start trying to force
yourself into going in that direction
and really I'm just speaking to the
small group of people that are watching
or listening to the show that actually
have that skill of being able to when
they're passionate work their faces off
and that is one of the competitive
advantages one of my favorites mine in a
lot of ways but doesn't have to be yours
so you know 20 how the question was
asked because I think it's a leading
question to you know if they only if
they work like Steve Wright you know if
they work like Steve here right so you
know that's not the issue at hand at all
I think I think the only sin and the
quickest way to get fired from
vaynermedia is to not figure out a way
to play nice with the other boys and
girls that you work with to me the
number one thing that I judge Vayner
media
lays on is how they interact with every
other vaynermedia employee some people
in the organization are really good at
leading their teams they have 1215
people and their team loves them to
death and they love their team to death
however cross-department if they're on
account with with with creative or with
the paid team or with you know IT or the
video production team they're not as
good they're fighting just for their
team and they're burning bridges in
those departments not good
other people are tremendous with clients
and are great with the other senior
people but they're not treating the
people underneath them with the respect
and their team doesn't love working for
them or they're micromanaging them and
so you know managing Styles don't bother
me people have to learn their cadence on
micromanaging versus giving people air
cover
but being disrespectful or being selfish
to what's in your best interest not the
logos interest as a whole within the
organization to me is just completely
unacceptable letting your emotions get
the best of you and talking down to
somebody or creating conflict
unacceptable and so those are the things
that are these sins within my
environment and so damn true right video
videos their biggest failure you've had
either in your business or in life
that's propelled you forward towards the
most success also hope to see you next
week as I film the Gary Vee show with
you thank you that's a great job Aaron
sorry you lost
great question love love the video you
know I think you know I've been lucky I
think the one failure I've had was that
2009 to 2011 window where I was trying
to be Gary Vee cuz a crush it I was
running Wine Library I we started
vaynermedia Misha was just born I was
trying to do obsess TV I was trying to
do the wine social network worked I was
trying to do the the social network for
developers and designer
called forest and I was very stretched
then I was investing and so I learned
that I was trying to definitely put my
ass on too many toilets that's a Russian
translation for all you lose skis out
there you know exactly what I'm talking
about and so I wasn't I wasn't able to
balance all of that and even now I
really I feel like I'm starting to take
on a lot of stuff the difference is I
did a better job up front that was more
selective of the people that I've
partnered with on rezian faithbox and
brave Ventures and then on you know I've
just I've and and and this has nothing
to do with the obsessed of forest or
cork team
I picked partners that I needed to
provide too many things too besides
capital and made those promises so it's
my failure not theirs this time around I
found people who had skills that were
more similar to mine I also had a
dramatically more infrastructure with
vaynermedia and my team and so you know
the rocks helped out with faithbox
you know and so you know zach has helped
out with with brave
you know everybody's helped out a little
bit here with resi you know and you know
and so there's a that's really it my man
that I've been very very very lucky I I
think for the most part I think in only
it you know this is the reason I
struggled with yesterday's question of
what I don't like about myself I think
there's something interesting in a way
that I process that I'm really getting
deeper into myself through this show
through your comments just really really
gathering a lot of pieces right now and
what I've realized is wow I am really a
net-net guy I mean if you think about
all the things that are not working in
my world right now there's a time there
is a ton of [ __ ] not working out there
different initiatives different
departments a ton but I can't help but
not recognize that we're gonna grow you
know outrageously this year and be
massively successful and so it's the
same you know there's probably tons of
flaws with me from yesterday's question
I'm just not capable of seeing them
because I think in a net-net game I'm a
decent dude and so one thing I would
implore and one thing I would challenge
and one thing I would actually want so
many of you to shift into is why are you
allowing yourself
to look at every small loss along the
way instead of taking a step back and
looking at minimally a year but you know
preferably a five-year window and saying
have you won in that environment and so
who cares if you do only investments
I've lost on you know like in the last
two years you know buddy
you know we employees didn't work out
you know how many flights I took that
took up a lot of time that materialized
them to nothing you know how many
negative comments I've gotten about this
show like you're allowing yourself and
this is based on your DNA and so listen
if you don't need to go and speak to
somebody and lay on a couch if you need
to write and express yourself if you
find your way to level up your ability
to look at things at a net score versus
the my new show from a day to day week
to week month to month lost game and I
promise you you will have a happier and
more successful career slash life Jay
asks if you're in a wholesale business
where volume is more important than
content how would you take advantage of
social media Jay what's the matter with
you
volumes more important than content
everywhere because volume of selling
[ __ ] is what you do for a living
regardless of you so weird looking
statues or phones or I love take it off
kicks you know like like volume always
matters content is a liaison to more
volume right my content wasn't more
important on Wine Library TV it was the
fact that that led to selling stuff and
so whether you're in wholesale or retail
or b2b or b2c the end goal within the
context is to drive a result including
if you're a non-profit you're not making
content that's gonna make somebody cry
about you know the the the dogs in the
wild that we need to save because you
just want somebody to cry no you want
them to take out their wallet this is
what you want J you want them to take
out their wallet and give them the cash
right that's what you want and so please
don't get it twisted
anybody that so much of this is
predicated on how do you provide value
- then have leverage to get the result
that you're looking for and so sorry I
got a little bit heated there for a
second
word it for me one more time yeah I mean
no I mean you know you know you take it
first of all when you're in wholesale
you're in the b2b business so you have
an easy in my opinion go and map who
your customers are to go to Facebook
run ads against the companies of the
people that you're trying to reach
employees of the company you're trying
to sell this go run it against
footlocker employees people that work at
Fuller do you guys have Facebook
accounts do and this I feel like people
haven't been updating them as well but
the data is still incredible at scale
this is just a quick test do any of you
have put vaynermedia in your profile all
five of you even better than I thought
you can reach all five of these
characters by targeting employees of
vaynermedia as a matter of fact somebody
could have probably been flown in next
Friday if they were smart enough to
spend $40 40 measly dollars on ads
against vaynermedia employees where they
used the vaynermedia employees to
pressure me to bring that person but you
didn't you just didn't and so execution
my friends and being a practitioner is
always always better than headline
reading and so I will tell you it is
very easy LinkedIn Facebook target your
actual customer and then make content
that is valuable to them right which
means different than b2c so back to this
I'm a sneaker producer of new I've got
to compete with Under Armour Nike and
Reebok and bloomin crap maybe my ad is
hey introducing the new Garry sneaker
more profitable for you than the others
yeah like literally it is a b2b
promotion right like here's a chart this
is what you make on all these other
characters or they bring people in but
here's my offer and I'm able to bring
you dramatically more profit and as a
kicker if you email me back I will also
run ad dollars directly to your store
for my sneaker because you're one of
first hundred people to contact me my
business man it's how my brain thinks
simon Sinek Simon my man such a good
dude a lot of people love him a lot of
people you guys know him he's the best
you guys are about to love him he's
unbelievable gary simon Sinek here hope
you're well I'm well son I have a
question about social media as you know
I'm a humanist and I'm really big into
human beings hanging out with human
beings and building real relations me
too Simon and I love technology and I
love social media but I'm also aware
that there's a balance and that if
things go out of balance it can actually
hurt the relationships that we form and
it's amazing for me sometimes to watch
people you know every notification they
get their Instagram their Facebook their
Twitter everything that shows up on the
top of their phones they can't help but
look down and and see what's going on my
question to you is do you think that
companies who use social media as a
primary means of marketing or any means
of marketing for that matter have a
responsibility to actually help us find
that balance do they have a
responsibility to help us manage our
real relationships or is it entirely the
responsibility of the user thanks for
help no Simon first of all since we're
buddies I'm dying to have dinner let's
get together cuz I'm gonna ask you
questions like do you think that it's
the responsibility of New York City to
limit the size of sodas or is that the
responsibility of for us do you think
that it is the responsibility of
McDonald's to no longer make anything
that is over a hundred and eighty
calories or is it the responsibility of
us do we think that we should you know
it's a very very syllabary slope right I
mean I think that politicians and other
humans have for a long time tried to say
we know what's better for the user than
the user themselves not to mention in a
business environment as you know Simon
you know Dunkin Donuts and Starbucks and
Peet's Coffee could be like cool we're
gonna do this we're gonna limit we're
gonna only tweet and post on Instagram
three times a day and then like Gary's
coffees gonna swoop in and do it all day
long and
results in the white space and the other
companies were like screw that we're
back and so I think I think it's an
interesting question I also think if
this gives me an opportunity to go there
Simon to say the following I promise you
that when you and I go and have these
drinks for dinner in a couple weeks that
I will rarely look at my phone if at all
you know why cuz you're interesting cuz
I like you
cuz I don't see you that often and
because that's what I want to be doing
when I'm there on the flipside if me and
Stefan were just going to hang out right
now for a quick coffee I might look at
my phone a couple of times I get to see
him more often we might not have we
don't that much to talk about right this
second you know instead like I'm gonna
I'm gonna be choosing what I want to do
besides what I'm doing right there I
think that us people looking at phones
looking at notifications is actually a
indicator of what we value I you know
not to take a drive with my mom will not
be looking at my phone so much because I
miss my mom and I want to hang out but
but if I saw her mom every single day I
promise you I probably would which is
the truth it's just us choosing what we
want and so technology has given us
options you know I always talk about the
couple that you see in a restaurant
where like meal as you walk in well meal
is you don't talk about this because of
my point of view but I know so many of
you have walked into a restaurant and
you've seen a couple and literally both
them they're on the phone the whole time
and you and your partner are having
dinner or and saying like look how sad
that is right all of you have done that
or you know at least you've heard of
somebody doing that or you've been part
part of a party to me I don't think that
people recognize that same couple 20
years ago they just sat and eat dinner
in silence looking at each other have
you seen that weird thing have you seen
that weird thing India yeah it's weird
it's weird so I actually am happy for
that couple because instead of what they
would have had to do 20 years ago which
is sit there in silence there at least
actually like keeping up with the ball
game
looking up on her Instagram deciding
what they'd rather do in that moment
than hang out with the other person
because they don't have a great marriage
or a great relationship that's just real
I mean this is real dynamics I think
it's a very dangerous slope to say look
all these relationships how sad is this
human interaction when you have
absolutely zero triple zero
double zero Robert Parrish triple zero
trip follow me here in Iraq triple zero
context to what's actually going on in
the relationship you don't need people I
got it the rock you know me people are
in you know out in public with each
other that hate each other at that
moment that are struggling they're
having problems that are in verge of
breaking up that or have a business
issue at hand there's so many dynamics
and I have no interest in sitting on a
pedestal and saying they should be
interacting with each other and so yeah
I think there's a responsibility and I
think the responsibility goes in many
different directions and I think that
it's a tremendously interesting question
I still think that ultimately it's very
difficult to do anything other than to
rely on the end-user to do what's best
for her or him and so that's kind of
where I sit on the issue
cool good job Simon I really appreciate
it
vaynernation if you don't know Simon is
please look him up I'm an enormous
enormous man I think it's a tremendous
human being a week it's really funny I
think by the way we agree on so so damn
much so much I really enjoy him and and
I very much just wanted we know I
believe tremendously in human
interaction
I believe technology is the greatest
gateway drug to more human interaction
there's no question in my life not even
an ounce of doubt that overlap if I look
at the last three years of my life the
time that I've spent with people that I
would never in a million years had those
moments just a decade earlier because
there was no infrastructure of
technology to be the liaison to make
those events happen I think it's very
easy and simple to look at technology as
taking away from those events I think it
is clear to me I hope to be right
long-term on this issue it is clear to
me that it is actually expanding our
ability to spend more time with people I
really believe that I believe that your
more constant con you just sit for five
seconds to think about all the high
school and college friends that your
older brothers or parents never have
that you or me never had the chance of
staying in touch with I'm perfect age if
you're in my age 38 to 42 think about
those first 10 years at a school where
we lost touch with all our friends and
then Facebook came along and we
reconnected and all the times that I've
been able to
now with with tea Adam Blum and Ken
Scalf oh and Mike Eisenhart like these
are moments I would have mikeandlindsey
isin art came and had dinner with me
downstairs a year ago I would have never
seen them again I would have never seen
them again that night meant so much to
me reminiscing about high school things
that I never thought of so I think it's
very very simple very very very simple
very very simple to blame technology and
think it's taking away I think it's
enabling flip side now if the winners
should announce some winners huh or in
India I know we have a tremendous
gentleman from Vermont uh I know we have
an immigrant yes from from Haiti I think
and a lovely young man Dallas who
actually I met and uh in LA so and you
know I gotta tell you a good story
I met Dallas in LA for the talk I gave
the other day and he said you're gonna
you said something to me like I'm gonna
win the contest and many people have
said that to me you're all ready for the
last week and I was like yeah okay
really I mean like if not in a bad way
I'm a good guy I'm like let's see but
she was an awesome dude and I met his
brother Austin and then I made a joke
I'm like where's your sister Houston and
and then they said our mom said if we
had another brother would be Tyler and
so but he won pretty impressive I gotta
give him gaps so Dallas Matthew
yep there's from Vermont yes and Webley
I'm massively excited I know that I know
that Dallas hasn't gotten back to us yet
but Matthew and Webley are excited like
like let's get with India here the money
like that like they really freaked their
[ __ ] yeah Matthew said I don't my
roommates don't understand why I'm
freaking out right now
I love it where is it they're really
nice he knows India cinnamon just
closing my laptop to go out to dinner I
saw the email mid close MIT close II saw
the email I love it I love it he's in
shock I love it I'm so excited
hablas got a glamorous picture
I'm so close yes yes yes yes it so cool
I'm very very very excited I think next
Friday is going to be an amazing day
question of the day what what plans do
you have for this weekend and the part
two a little bit more detailed what is
your latest website obsession what is
the website or app that is most catching
your attention that is new to you in the
last 60 75 days you keep asking
questions I'll keep answering them
[Music]